♪
>> I JUST BUILD ON THE.
HAPPY FRIDAY, AMERICA.
HOW IS YOUR CIVIL WAR GOING?
I KNOW IT'S CRAZY OUT THERE.
I NEARLY GOT HIT BY A CANNONBALL
.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE BRIAN STELTER
BACK AT WORK.
HOME HE.
ONCE AGAIN, LET'S LOOK AT WHAT
THE MEDIA DEVICE AS HARMED
VERSUS WHAT REAL HARM IS BRADY
PROBABLY DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT THE
MACHETE ATTACK IN NEW YORK TWO
DAYS AGO.
THAT'S RIGHT, I SAID MACHETE.
WHO KNEW WE LIVE IN THE
BRAZILIAN RAIN FOREST?
THERE WAS A MACHETE ATTACK IN
NEW YORK, AND GET THIS, IT WAS
REPEAT MACHETE ATTACK BY A
REPEAT MACHETE ATTACKER WHO HAD
BEEN ARRESTED SEVERAL TIMES
INCLUDE THE ATTACKING PEOPLE
WITH MACHETES.
HE ALSO ATTACKS PEOPLE WITH BEA
SPRAY WHICH IS ONLY SUPPOSED TO
BE USED ON BRITT BEAR.
HE ACTUALLY LIKES IT.
THE PSYCHO MUST BE WONDERING
WHAT'S IT GOT TO TAKE TO GET
ARRESTED IN NEW YORK.
SHE MUST BE GETTING MACHETE
ELBOW.
DAYS AFTER BEING RELEASED THIS
YOUNG BLACK WOMAN WAS OUT ON TH
STREET ATTACK AND ATTACKED AN
OLDER BLACK DOORMAN.
NOT MUCH OF A STORY BECAUSE THE
VARIABLES ARE ALL WRONG.
SHE'S NOT EXTREME IN THIS ARE
FOR PEOPLE WHO DRESS AS VIKINGS
AT THE CAPITAL.
AND THEN SMILED LIKE IT WAS HIS
HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOK PHOTO AND
HE'D BEEN VOTED CLASS CLOWN.
THIS WAS ALSO A REPEAT OFFENDER
WHO'D BEEN CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER, IT WAS
DOWNGRADED.
I GUESS WE WOULD HEAR MORE ABOU
IT IF HE WAS EXTREME MAGA, BUT
HE'S NOT.
LIKE ALEC BALDWIN, THEY WILL
JUST BLAME THE GUN.
TO SOON?
BECAUSE REMEMBER, THE REAL WAR
IS BETWEEN MAGA AND DEMOCRACY.
IT'S LIKE WHEN JAWS MADE PEOPLE
AFRAID OF.
SHARKS.
I MUST BE OLD.
IN MY REALLY OLDER THAN THE
AUDIENCE?
I'M GOING TO NEED SOME RELIEF
FACTOR.
ANYWAY, DO YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENE
IN LAS VEGAS?
A HUGE STORY, AND NOTABLE
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST THIS
JOURNALIST WAS FOUND STABBED TO
DEATH.
THIS IS THE KIND OF STORY THAT
ENRAGES JOURNALIST, ONE OF THEI
OWN GETS TAKEN OUT.
HE'D BEEN ACTIVELY WRITING ABOU
VEGAS CORRUPTION AND WAS STABBE
TO DEATH BY SOMEONE HE MADE MAN.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A SCENE OUT OF
CASINO OR ON KAT'S.
THE DNA WAS FOUND UNDER THE
FINGERNAILS.
I GUESS THIS IS WHAT BIDEN WAS
WARNING US ABOUT.
THESE EXTREME MAGA TYPES LASHIN
OUT.
THE ACCUSED KILLER IS DEMOCRATI
LEADER, A DEMOCRAT POLITICIAN I
VEGAS.
NO WONDER THE MEDIA ABANDON THE
STORY LIKE IT WAS ASHLEY BIDENS
DIARY.
A LOT OF IMPORTANT TIPS ON
BATHING IN THERE.
THAT IS VAGUE ENOUGH.
RIGHT?
IF YOU READ THE HEADLINES OR
SKIM THE ARTICLES YOU WOULD
NEVER KNOW THE KILLER IS A
DEMOCRAT, WHICH I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND.
BECAUSE WHOEVER WRITES THE
ARTICLE HAS TO FIGURE THE KILLE
WILL PROBABLY BE OUT OF JAIL IN
MERE MONTHS, AND WE KNOW HOW TH
KILLER FEELS ABOUT JOURNALIST T
WRITE BAD THINGS ABOUT HIM.
SO REALLY, THERE IS NO NEED TO
RUB HIS NOSE IN THAT.
JUST CALL HIM OFFICIAL.
I THINK A REPUBLICAN WOULD GET
THE SAME TREATMENT IF YOU
MURDERED SOMEONE?
THEY ARE WAY AHEAD OF ME.
YOUR RIGHT, BUT YOU KNEW THAT.
THE FACT IS THE PAPER THAT THE
DEAD JOURNALIST WORKED ON WAS
ONE OF THE FEW REPUBLICANS OWNE
PAPERS OF THIS ATTACK WAS NOT
JUST AGAINST ONE REPORTER BUT A
ENTIRE STAFF PAPER.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T GIVE A [BLEEP
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON THE SAME
TEAM.
THE RACE THE POLITICAL
AFFILIATION LIKE IT WAS A
BIOLOGICAL WOMAN.
NOW, MAKING CRIME FUNNY, IT'S
HARD.
NOW, IF THE SITUATION WE'RE
REVERSED, THEN YOU WOULD KNOW
THE HEADLINE.
REPUBLICAN MURDERS BRAVE
JOURNALISTS.
I'M SORRY, IT WOULD BE EXTREME
MAGA MURDERS JOURNALIST FRED
WOMEN AND MINORITIES HIT HARDEST
.
EXPERTS CLAIM TRUMP AND CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND, IT WOULD BE WOVEN INTO THE
FANTASY OF THE SO-CALLED MAGA
CIVIL WAR.
EVEN JOE BIDEN WOULD HAVE HIS
HANDS AT HALF-MAST.
PATRIOTIC.
BUT SINCE THE STORY DOESN'T FIT
THAT CRITERIA, IT HEADS TO
OBLIVION LAKE CRYSTAL PEPSI AND
DAN RATHER.
NO POLITICAL CAPITAL TO BEGIN
WHEN JOURNALIST IS MURDERED BY
DEMOCRAT.
NOW INCOMES OBAMA WHO IGNORES
ALL THIS MAYHEM LIKE HE DID WIT
ISIS.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS WHO'D POLICIES LEAD T
ME CORP. MORE CRIME.
IT'S NOT ALL THE SENSELESS
MURDERS YOU SEE, IT'S THE
COMPLAINTS COMPLAINT ABOUT THE
SENSELESS MURDERS.
REMEMBER WHEN THE MEDIA WAS
HAPPILY WITH LINK BY JESSE
SMOLLETT.
IT'S HAPPENING AGAIN BUT AT A
GREATER SCALE.
THE MEDIA PORTRAYS THE COUNTRY
IS A MASSIVE SWALWELL GETTING
READY TO GET ATTACKED BY RACIST
IN RED HATS.
SWALWELL HAS BECOME THE
BY GIVING THE PARTY A ROADMAP
THAT RUNS RIGHT THROUGH THE
COUNTRY.
STOKING FEELER THROUGH
FABRICATION OF AN ENEMY.
NOW ARE LIVING IN A WAR OF THE
VERSION OF HATE CRIME HOAXES, I
THE MEDIA WILL ALWAYS DEFEND TH
HOOK SAYING IT'S TRUE SOMEWHERE
IF NOT HERE.
WHILE THAT IS HAPPENING.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN ILLINOIS.
IN ANOTHER STATE GETS RID OF NO
CASH BAIL BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A
ROUSING SUCCESS EVERYWHERE ELSE.
HERE IS WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> FOR ALMOST EVERY OFFENSE FOR
THIS INCLUDES, BUT ISN'T LIMITE
TO, KIDNAPPING, ARMED ROBBERY,
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER, DRUG
INDUCED HOMICIDE, AGGRAVATED DUI
, THREATENING A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL AND AGGRAVATED FLEEING
AND ELUDING.
OFFENDERS ARE AFTER THE
VIOLATION FOR 48 HOUR'S BEFORE
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN ACT FRAYED
THEY CAN ALMOST DRIVE TO ALASKA.
BEFORE WE CAN EVEN LOOK FOR THEM
.
IT DENIES VICTIMS THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND KEEP
THIS IN MIND, BUSINESSES AND
HOMEOWNERS, OFFICERS WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO REPORT PRESS
PACERS FROM YOUR RESIDENCE OR
YOUR BUSINESSES.
SOMEONE COULD DECIDE TO LIVE IN
YOUR SHED, AND ALL WE CAN DO IS
GIVE THEM A TICKET.
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT LEVEL O
FORCE IS REQUIRED TO REMOVE THEM
.
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S LEGAL.
ACUTE THANK GOD I DON'T OWN A
SHED.
I THINK THAT'S THE LESSON WE AL
LEARNED HERE.
IT IS AMAZING EGG KILLER CAN
DRIVE FOR ALASKA BEFORE COPS CA
LOOK FOR HIM.
THE ONLY PERSON I KNOW WHO LIVE
IN ALASKA BESIDE SARAH PALIN AN
WE DON'T TALK MUCH.
SARAH AND I.
NOW POLITICAL LEADERS, THEY HAD
ONE JOB TO MAINTAIN ORDER SEEK
AND LIVE A SOMEWHAT SECURE LIFE.
HERE THEY REJECTED UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT SUCH LAWS DON'T
WORK FOR CERTAIN PEOPLE, WHICH
IS RACIST, BUT THEN THEY CALL
YOU RACIST FOR COMPLAINING ABOU
IT SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS DAYS TOWN
PHANTOMS WITH REDHEADS, YOU WIL
SEE MORE DEATHS FROM WHIPPING I
BREATHING CRIMINALS AND IT
PROVES WHAT HAPPENS IN VEGAS
WON'T ALWAYS STAY IN VEGAS
BECAUSE ALL THEY DO IS BET ON
RED.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS,
SHE IS OUR OVERALL FAVORITE
GUEST IS AN GUEST THAT WEARS
OVERALLS, THAT WAS FUNNY, GUYS.
PLEASE, BELIEVE US, HIS NAME IS
JESUS, THE GREAT SOCIAL
SCIENTIST IN YOUTUBE
EXTRAORDINARY HOTEL JESUS.
HE MAY BE THE ONLY PERSON BETTE
OF WEARING A BARREL, DON'T BE
ROOM FOR THOSE CARTOONS?
WITH THE BARREL?
AND IN FOUR KAT.
SO BRIGHT HE GETS A TAN BY
LOOKING IN THE MIRROR.
I WANT TO GO TO YOU BECAUSE AS
HOMELESS PERSON, YOU MUST BE
TERRIFIED LIVING ON THE STREETS
WHEN YOU SEE THE CONSTANT
RECIDIVISM THAT SOMEBODY COULD
COME OUT AND TAKE YOUR BLANKET
AND THEN GET ARRESTED AND THEY
COME BACK OUT AND THEY TAKE YOU
PANTS.
>> THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT TOTALLY
SCARY.
THE REPEAT MACHETE LADY, THAT I
HORRIBLE.
THE BEAR SPRAY TOO.
SHE'S GETTING THEM BLIND AND
THEN WHACKED RICKY KEVIN LIKE
ANY OF IT.
AFTER DURING STATEMENT.
>> AND YOU SEE WHAT'S COMING
WITH THE CHICAGO AND ALL OF
ILLINOIS.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE JUST PLANING
ON A LIVE ACTION ROLE-PLAY OF
THE BIRDS.
YOU CAN PRACTICALLY HEAR THE
PEOPLE AT U-HAUL COUNTING THE
MONEY.
>> CAN'T THIS BE STOPPED?
TO GET THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE T
STOP IT.
THEY REALLY ARE.
IT HURTS EVERYBODY.
I EVEN FEEL BAD FOR THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COMING TO AMERICA
WHEN THEY FIND OUT THEY'RE GOIN
TO CHICAGO.
RIGHT?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S COME AT THE
MAYOR THAT.
HEAR SAID IT WAS CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE YOU LEAVE
VENEZUELA, YOU ARE MARCHING
THROUGH THE JUNGLE THAN THERE'S
DRUG DEALERS TRYING TO KEEP YOU
IN THEN MACHETE PEOPLE, YOU GO
ACROSS THE DESERT WITH NO WATER
YOU FINALLY GET TO TEXAS IN YOU
LIKE WE MADE IT TO THE LAND OF
MILK AND HONEY, AND THEY SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO CHICAGO.
ISN'T THERE ROOM ON THE NEW YOR
BEST BUS?
I COULD GET IN THE OVERHEAD BIN.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU BEAR THE
FIRST AMENDMENT YOU.
I FEEL LIKE A KNOW YOU BECAUSE
WATCH A MANY OF YOUR PODCAST IN
YOU'RE STREAMING IN ALL THAT
STUFF.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
SITUATION?
YOU TALK ABOUT THE STUFF OF THE
TIME.
>> DON LEMON WEREN'T SAID THE
BEST THE GREATEST TERROR THREAT
IN AMERICA IS WIGHTMAN.
USUALLY HE DOESN'T TELL THE
TRUTH BUT AT THAT POINT HE WAS
RIGHT BECAUSE THAT WHITE MAN
LOOK JUST LIKE JOE BIDEN.
>> DON'T YOU LOVE THOUGH THAT
HE'S NOW THE LAW & ORDER
PRESIDENT?
HE SEEMS TO BE WORKING FOR HIM.
>> WHEN WAS HE NOT THE LAW AND
ORDER PRESIDENT.
I HAVE UNCLES IN JAIL RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF HIM.
>> BUT NOW HE HAS DISOWNED THAT
PART OF HIM.
HE HAS CHANGED.
>> WITH THIS SOCIALIST, WHAT
THEY LIKE TO DO IS CREATE CHAOS.
CHAOS BRINGS NECESSITY.
SO THEY CAN COME IN AND LOCK
EVERYBODY UP.
HE'S GOT TO BRING UP AN
INTERNATIONAL POLICE YOU THINK
HE'S GOTTEN STARTED?
>> SO WHAT IS THE NEXT STEP?
ARE YOU BELIEVING IN CONSPIRACY?
>> I AM.
I REALLY BELIEVE THEY WANT TO
MAKE THINGS SO DESTITUTE AND SO
DANGEROUS THAT THEY WILL HAVE T
SAY FUND THE POLICE.
THERE GOING TO BRING THEM IN
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES AND WHATNOT
.
SO IT WILL BE A POLICE STATES.
I DON'T LISTEN TO ALEX JONES.
YOU KNOW, HE SPEAKS SOME SENSE.
I'M GOING TO BE BUYING A BIG
CANISTER OF GREEN.
YOU KNOW THOSE COMMERCIALS.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE A SHED.
I HATE EVERYBODY.
WOULD YOU MAKE OF THIS, WHAT AR
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> ON THE ILLINOIS STORY, I LOV
HOW THE ILLINOIS STATE
LEGISLATURE IS LIKE WE THINK
CHICAGO IS TO SAVE, WE WANTED T
BE LIKE THE BIG APPLE, WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO.
THE MARKETING ARM FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY KNOW THA
THE ONLY WAY REPUBLICANS MOVE
THIS ELECTION IS THEY DON'T
FOCUS ON CRIME IN THE ECONOMY.
REPUBLICANS GETS A LITTLE
DISTRACTED, TAKING THE BAIT FRO
THE DEMOCRAT.
THE DEMOCRAT RUN MEDIA KNOWS IF
THEY DO STORIES ABOUT THE CRIME
PUTS CRIME IN THE WITH THE TWO
MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THAT OR THEY GET BOOKS
READ.
>> IT SEEMS TO BE WORKING IN TH
SENSE THAT THE MEDIA IS AGAIN
AMPLIFYING IT.
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO WATCH
TELEVISION TO KNOW HOW BAD IT I
BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE IT WHEN YOU
WALK OUT YOUR FRONT DOOR.
IF THERE IS NEVER ANYBODY IN
YOUR GARAGE OR LAUNDRY ROOM,
JUST GIVE ME A CALL.
I HAVE BEEN CARRYING A HAMMER
AND MY PURSE, WHICH MY FATHER
TOLD ME, YOU BETTER HAVE SOME
PICTURE HANGERS IN THAT PURSE
WITH YOU IN CASE SHE GETS.
>> THAT IS RIGHT, CARRY A
PAINTING WITH YOU AT ALL TIMES.
AND THEN PULL OUT THE HAMMER AN
SMACK THEM.
TICKET NO, YOU NEED SOME PICTUR
HANGERS AND A LITTLE PHOTO
BECAUSE YOU NEED A REASON TO BE
CARRYING THE HAMMER WITH YOU.
I AM DEAD SERIOUS.
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
>> JUST A REMINDER, IT IS THE
REAL THREAT TO THAT REPUBLIC IS
DONALD TRUMP WITH THE TOWEL AND
THE FOLDERS AND THE DOCUMENTS H
TOOK TO HIS HOUSE, THINK OF THE
HELL HE WOULD BRING UPON THIS
NATION WITH PAPER CUTS.
THEY STING.
THEY GET SORE.
WHAT IF THEY GET INFECTED?
THAT'S HORRIBLE.
>> BY THE WAY.
PAPER CUTS HURT MORE THAN
ANYTHING.
RIGHT?
IT'S BECAUSE THIS AREA IS VERY
SENSITIVE, THAT'S A YOU TOUCH
THINGS, SO WHEN YOU RUN IT ALON
IT IS WORSE THAN GETTING STABBE
IN THE EYE.
BY THE WAY, I WONDER IF YOUR DAD
'S LOGIC WORKS WITH A NAIL
GUN.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAD A NAIL GUN
THAN YOU COULD FIRE THE NIELS.
I'M GOING TO DO ATKINS.
I'M A BIT CONFUSED.
SO IF SOMEBODY IS HIDING IN YOU
SHED, YOU CAN'T REMOVE THEM, BU
I REMOVE HIM, BUT I REMOVE HIM,
DO I GO TO JAIL?
>> THAT'S WHAT WE WERE SAYING.
>> AND LESS YOU HAVE PICTURE
HANGERS?
YOU ARE HANGING A PICTURE IN
YOUR SHED.
HANG A PICTURE IN YOUR SHED,
PROBLEM SOLVED.
THEN RENTED OUT TO THE HOMELESS
PERSON.
CALL IT A TINY HOME.
>> WHAT A SCAM THAT IS TINY HOME